sembra album perfetto per iniziare
un'altra puntata di residenti volumi
ciao ragazzi vi ringrazio
anticipatamente per gli auguri perché i
commenti immagino che poi magari lo
ricorda nessuno chi se ne frega però
oggi calcio 25 anni grazie mille degli
auguri che mi avrete già fatto e io vi
sto rispondendo
nel passato perché lo so già domani
uscirà un video specialissimo per i 25
anni miei che mi sono fatto da solo
perché manca vito mi regalano manco
quelli va bè ragazzi eravamo rimasti che
stavo qua dentro come faccia superare
questo qua porca vacca nicchia avere la
diventi testa di culo mi chiamo di
proiettile in faccia come se niente
fosse cioè lo zio orco lo stesso
accarezza poi aiuto ora è il nuovo turno
di paura che ciò maori
minchia sparato sei volte fa scavati a
che cacchio ora che non ne ho ragazzi
quella che i proiettili del fucile non
sono facili da trovare o questi qua per
farli volevo fare 87 usa le 86
proiettili ho visto io non ce la faccio
lo dico subito io questi qua non non c'è
verso non posso farli fuori tutti quanti
perché se ne spunta un altro giorno
riescono più colpi ma dico ci sono già
stato non ci sono passato e lì non ci
potevo andare devo andare a mettere la
chiave che sta qua ma edizione vorrei
fare tutto indietro appendiamo perfetto
allora mettiamo il coso qua incredibile
le porte con la batteria e black iii le
lepri le io non ho veramente le fogne
americane proprio 8 kg le batterie no
ragazzi però va veramente cioè per
cortesia
ve lo chiedo per cortesia maori aprista
bocca c'è uno almeno uno solo ma non
farmi notare più di uno per ammazzarlo
mi cacci
minchia già sono introvabili sti
proietti almeno un proiettile solo più
di uno me ne andavo a farmi fotter
questa si può aprire grazie a venire a
cio di aspetta posso aprire due porte
con la batteria dalla stessa formula
prenderti già a batteria vede prima
prima questa anche se sei lunga però
voglio fare prima quella giu
andiamo a no no mica questo vi serviva
come l'aria tantissimo mi serve a primis
da porsche se può bucare i trend rondò
minchia ho sempre più alle ricorso fosse
che è poco visto tutto finora tranne le
incendiarie che lasciati indietro no se
quindi a posto ogni volta che ultima
carlos miliardario si sia tentato di
mangiarmi la faccia a 89 lumache giganti
ma va bene alle tartarughe ninja era
noto ieri qui siamo usciti dalle fogne
perfetto ottimo tempismo in prossima
volta non parlo più tranquillo e penso
che le fogne durassero molto di più
serve a posto beh no no attenzione che
sta per sparare quello è io te l'ho
detto
c'era gente che non ho visto che c'è la
gente questo forse solo contro il
nemesis nicchia dove minchia l'ha preso
un lanciafiamme quello numeri zombie che
è successo
no no come vicky entrato quello porca
vacca con le scale mobili aiuto
no no volevo rimanere a guardarlo io
pensate che coincidenza
ragazzi backspin butta giù butta giù
veloce però quanto tempo minchia che
precisione poi una ragazza finisco
malissimo
so che devo fare in fretta che sono
volumi in groppa
non so se non ci passa la sopra lui come
ci è passato basali mi piace caldo sento
caldo io no ragazzi veramente
incredibile passiamo è sì veramente male
ma ecco come ha fatto lui c'ha le liane
mischia corri e cosa gliene frega lui di
far fuori mesto testa di culo cosa te ne
frega dio mio che palle cosa c'è contro
lime questo
no io veramente no
solo perché sto monetizzando sulla tua
faccia dei sei tranquillo zio non è che
l'alto ragazze saliamo ancora un po e vi
devo buttare come in assassin's creed
come faccio poi a scendere la smettiamo
di salire ecco porca vacca veloce
chi ha movenze di mia nonna oddio scena
boss fight porca vacca contro il nemesis
l'inter ci credo sapevo che
e mo che devo fare ma fatti sotto cosa
questo qua ma come è ovvio
forse gli faccio salta sti cosi come
faccio no ragazzi scusate me non hanno
propriamente tanto non ce la posso fare
hai capito che è imbattibile
allora io gli farò tutto quello che ti
giuro su dio che se non muore ha
sprecato proiettili mi incazzo vieni qua
uno sparava allora gli sparò la distanza
e basta
incendio io top ma auguri aiuto
condizioni esclusive
intanto saranno a fuoco quindi questo un
buon segno
let's golf tutto bene zio provava un
altro credono gli faccia una sega
proprio show sto presentimento di qua 6
coraggio che c'è il caso elettrico con
la faccia e ucciso cristo no niente
match inviato a fattor tu la mia sto
morendo e tutto a fuoco ma dove cazzo
vado non lo so ma va tutto a fuoco
basta devo fare ha dato a fuoco tutto ma
per forza del catania che è niente
andato a fuoco tutto rifacciamo o anche
volendo tre granate però le grate non
vorrei usarle male vorrei tenere occhi
occhio occhio anche su sfarinato cioè
mentre spara in alto di sparone pulizia
del così ben non si è fatto niente se
non li sente proietti non ce li ha
almeno gli arrivano nicchia quando si
sposta la roma più brutta del mondo le
granate uso quelle ci sono quelle che
perché di armi
vuoi morire è morto ma non è morto
sparito veloce spara di coach sacco di
proietti però
no ragazzi e sono alibi cos'è sta roba
qua
prendi il collo che cazzo aperto
cosa quarto tempo
è tanto sparata sui piedi ma ora che
pezzo di merda cosa devo fare queste
situazioni la granata di lancio mi
chiamo la schivate tutte e quindi hanno
forse l'unica e sparare a cosa elettrico
non lo so ragazzi aiuto santo iddio
quando vi segue proprio non ne vuole
sapere
prova a sparare al quadro elettrico che
non mi viene in mente niente altro
vediamo se funziona di nuovo ma che sei
arrivato liti sine die
ancora uno brava e mo no frate di morire
però che cacchio su due ore che gli
sparo basta non ho più proiettili zio
veramente non so più cosa fanno ce n'è
uno li santo gesù madonna che male stava
per far malissimo
prendi questo primo e non solo la fia
cartucce de che
ma che è non solo granata equipaggia buy
dichiara gas è veramente un omaggio così
non so cosa sparati di più
86 granate cioè ma vedete non ho preso
le cartucce mi piace rende le cartucce
utilissime va bene sono soddisfatto
mercato per le cartucce mi sarebbero
servite dai
beh comunque situazioni sempre un po di
merda è perfetto io mi sposterei
perfetto a cosa quando non funziona
l'ascensore eh va beh era una boss fight
assegni boss fight che alla fine hanno
fatto niente
no allora è stata una bella boss fight
per quanto gli uomini rosica che ho
lasciato poi quelle le cartucce che
trasmetteranno per il fucile sette colpi
non era male maledizione vabbè dai da ho
lasciato anche gli incendiari di
software che ci penso mi chiama un sacco
di roba come dai proviamo a far finta di
niente vedere se va tutto bene lo stesso
gunshot forse là dentro
trovo quello che mi serve allora gunshot
venivano 6 scatola qualcosa dentro
gunshot anche se dubito ma invece su
entrare ok sicuro qua dai podi proietti
ci saranno decreto canna lunga fucile a
pompa very good
però me la melo c'è mi diventa molto più
grosso è mannaggia
vabbè dai fa niente che non era male
neanche prima minchia l'espresso ragazzi
mi dovete mettere una stanza sicura
quadro che se non riesco a prendere
tutte le robe da di culo ma se si è più
o meno non volevo ma vai tranquillo
tanto fatto una bozza fa il binario ci
credo senti stiamo usando la metro per
fuggire dalla città
tu mi ami ma voglio stare qua
sembra un buon piano sono dice veramente
me ne vado da maria bringing bel da fare
potresti esserci d'aiuto
tutto ok
ma questo non era quello della bambina
no aspetta una cazzata
forse questo era quello della mamma rina
dei residenti vol 2 una calzata e non
quello che c'ha la bambina che era
rimasta zombie è quindi quello di fuori
credo e non vorrei dire una cazzata
potrebbe essere questo e mi confermate
nei commenti non sono serie ma di loro
non lo scarto ero mai immagino cioè non
sarà uno di quegli oggetti che proprio
mi portano fino alla fine pieno visti
lucchetti e poi tra l'altro preferivo
quando c'erano ripeto quando c'erano
quelli da dove devi inserire il codice
era meglio secondo me però beh perché
alle nuove vino oggetti in meno e dovevi
sbatterti per capitano sbattere non in
questo senso nel senso dove partì culo
ecco che sorpresa non è morto comunque
ma basta ma che cazzo ma chi è che viene
da queste armi corri santo iddio aspetta
al mio
meno male che è storto picchia che cosa
ho schivato occhio che c'è un tizio che
spara qua occhio di chi fa aiuto e ove
nora gara incredibile socio con ansia
madonna ma voi smetta è rotto miglia dai
passati la lo devo sorbire per forza
credo o no non lo store disco perché
madonna cosa schivato tra l'altro tutto
bene a quella zona i ragni che schifo
carlos tutto a posto
sì sì o predetto la sua domanda
guardate che sorpresa invece non è morto
non avrei mai detto
cosa facciamo corriamo
donna che è male e quindi ma cosa devo
fare qua ad andare di qua ma sono morto
di usare l'erba ma sono morto ormai
invece ce l'ho fatta da forse da dove
cacchio devo andare che culo mi ha fatto
superare l'ostacolo cioè che stava è
stata presa a lancia fiammate a lanciar
azzate in bocca è ancora viva tu sei
peggio del nemesis dialogo è possibile
tanto tempo che arrivo mi salta in bocca
un altra volta quindi fa niente adesso
guarda tanto scommetti che si parava
davanti loro fan hanno peggio è cascata
la testa santo iddio ci aspetta
ho dato henin chiama sparato tra l'altro
via via via via veloce che figata
stampante casca dalle star
eccolo superman arrivo è il cristo
madonna
e ho capito mela schivava questa questo
non potevo schivarla ma in africa
funzionare schiva bile basta cure il
cancello non ci passi avanti troppo
grosso carlos dammi una mano una mano
sia che botte sto prendendo da due ore
ma cosa c a questo per controlli ma chi
gliele d'aste armi quanti proiettili shy
mammina claymore certo adesso sì che
basta
tutti abbastanza e da noi
non è servito a niente ma come si è
curvata la serranda quello non si sarà
fatto nulla preso più scoppole quello
che non so ancora quanto quella che va
ridotto sto pezzente ho buttato l'erba o
dotato praticamente ci ha buttato no
perchè questo sarei morto però dai
veloce
minchia quanto vedere che stiamo qua
fare scampagnate quello sta fuori
che cacchio fanno questi arrivai altri
dai quanto tempo e non partirò mi
chiamano male è perché così almeno poi
poi di fare il gioco dal suo punto di
vista non ci sveglia adesso serve a
salvare la città presto politici si
filewave avanti ciao stato bello provato
di qua
che figata i poster ragazzini ma non lo
meriterò mai a vedere i fatti così bene
cioè non so giorno ragazzi sono tornata
grazie non ricordo sta per partire e
tornare in città e trovare i natali al
bar
vero sta tranquilla quando i civili
saranno in salvo il treno tornerà non
preoccuparti tu vai
non ho nessuna intenzione di morire non
so che non vuoi stare senza di me
sì certo che ci sa fare con le donne
le sue ricerche sul vaccino potrebbero
salvarci ma dona che gioca che lei
scusatemi è partito da loro i modelli la
sola cosa che conta nella tua mente
ecco detto questo sparagli buona
fortezza che ha detto sta cagata no si
parte
dai vecchi a riguardarlo così come se
avesse veramente fatto colpo ragazzi non
rimorchiate così non funziona questo
fascio la testa duomo non l'ho mai fatto
però immagino di sì credo che poi magari
hanno capito un cazzo io però che ci sei
preoccupata per i tuoi compagni o c'è
dell'altro
come ha fatto il plotone accadere
nell'imboscata di quegli stupidi strano
figlio ecco credo il nemesis
guardate che sorpresa agli atti fuori
tutti chi tra l'altro sulla ero tutti
morti per bellusci 4 sul vagone pezzo di
minchia
invece di usare le tue armi di merda non
potevi fare io
ciao
[Musica]
rilascia barca che botta ok mai
viaggiare senza biglietto penso sia la
morale di tutto ciò capito allora
impersona adesso io ma veramente è
quindi ragazzi qua finisce la parte 2 di
residenti voi ci vediamo a prossimo
episodio con la parte number free
diventa sempre a me piace a me piace
veramente tantissimo ci vediamo ragazzi
domani per il video speciale di 25 anni
un bacino e iscritti al canale per
ragazzi
[Musica]